emile halbout 45 en
piste donc 5ème vice président du
conseil départemental
délégué donc à l'insertion par
l'économie sociale et solidaire
ça ne m'arrive est un territoire
d'expérimentation qui est tourné vers la
terre vers la mer
c'est un territoire rural qui détient
des richesse foncière qu'il faut
développer à travers donc une action
publique forte et une représentation
fort du politique pour mettre en avant
les avantages les a tous les talents
sainte-marien au service du
développement de la cité
développer les chantiers d'insertion qui
vise à mettre en avant le monde agricole
le monde rural est également donc amené
ce qu'on appelle une politique de
proximité qui soit beaucoup plus appuyé
puisque nous avons des quartiers reculés
qui nécessitent une attention
particulière de la collectivité un
accompagnement soutenu une sociologie
sainte marienne qui nous amène à avoir
un regard beaucoup plus approfondie sur
le ressenti des populations qui
travaillent et vivent sur ces quartiers
reculés que son espérance la confiance
beaumont et qui pour autant nécessite
une attention particulière je n'oublie
pas évidemment le développement certain
samarie en matière démographique qui
nous amène aussi à avoir un rapport aux
administrés différents
département est avant tout un
accompagnateur social qui doit
effectivement accompagné la population
réunionnaise dans ses missions
principales que sont effectivement donc
l'aide aux plus démunis mais également
la problématique de l'insertion aller
encore plus loin pour créer ce qu'on
appelle des filières innovantes des
filières courtes je pense à
l'entrepreneuriat je pense à la
révolution numérique je pense aux
personnes vulnérables qui doivent aussi
avoir peut-être la possibilité de
bénéficier de circuits courts et c'est
tout ces interfaces qui toucha les ir à
l'humain et à l'épanouissement même des
populations qui doivent j'allais dire
attiré l'attention du département dans
son action quotidienne